si cinq cadavres retrouvés poings liés
sortie d'une cave là une fosse commune
remplie de personnes en habit civil
à bout de champ au nord de kiev les
autorités ukrainiennes présente à la
presse ce qu'elle dénonce comme des
crimes de guerre russes 300 civils
auraient été tués et le président
ukrainien après s'être rendu sur place
5e donc je
les occupants vont probablement essayer
de cacher les traces de leurs crimes ils
ne l'ont pas fait à abuja lorsqu'ils se
sont retirés mais dans une autre région
c'est possible
abuja la responsabilité russe ne fait
aucun doute pour kiev qui s'appuie
notamment sur ces images fournies par
des satellites américains elles
montreraient des corps de civils au bord
des routes dès la mi mars le kremlin
affirment que les corps ont été déposés
après le retrait de l'armée russe la
russie continue de dénoncer des mises en
scène
par les forces russes ont quitté la zone
de boudhha dès le 30 mars dans le cadre
d'un redéploiement paquin au
cours des trois jours suivants je le
maire de la ville s'est exprimé à la
télévision affirmant que la cité
retrouver une vie normale les forces du
craignent n ont également été vus et des
rues ont été montrées où il n'y avait
pas de cordes et n'est qu'un cure
les autorités russes affirment qu'elles
vont documenter ce qu'elle appelle la
vraie nature des événements à butch
moscou prévoit de présenter des preuves
de sa non implication au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu ce mardi